i want to start with congratulations on
your movie i really sincerely hope it's
a huge hit thank you me too i have a
million questions for you but i i have
been thinking about the fact like do you
think
sony
because movies are hard to get made yes
we all know this but do you think this
gets made without the success of like
black panther that sort of showed that
audiences will come out to see an
all-black cast i absolutely believe the
success of black panther opened the door
for this to be made
it was being developed prior to black
panther coming out but it didn't have
its green light
black panther changed everything changed
the game changed culture changed
perception
show the value in our stories and then
audiences come out and see our stories
so um thank you ryan coogler
for making such a dope movie um you
obviously i thought you did such a great
job with old guard and and that allowed
you to sort of play in that bigger
sandbox with action and you know more
than you had done previously yes what
did you learn making that that you sort
of brought with you into this
god so much i mean foremost uh that's
where i met danny hernandez he was my
fight coordinator in old guard he was my
second call when i got this i'm like i
need you to come with me onto this
journey because he's brilliant and our
collaboration was so good
um i understood what it
takes to
have to capture action it um
it sounds easy but it's not or obvious
if you do not have it on set you're not
going to have in the edit room and when
you're going you're on take 14 15 16 and
it's just not working
you can't stop you can't suddenly say
i'm running at a time and let's just
move on
so knowing how long you have to go at it
and how long the actors have to have
that type of stamina as well but all of
these actors they wanted to be great
they'd never quit um some of the moves
in there that you see in this film i
mean they did all that
um and they didn't quit till they got it
right yeah i'm gonna commend you on i
watch a lot of movies and one of the
things is i can totally tell when it's
the stunt double when you're seeing the
back of the head when there's like 20
cuts in three seconds you know to make
it look like there's action um and that
but you this is really being done on set
um and i'm listen i know you didn't have
like marvel money to make this so what
ended up being like the toughest thing
that like maybe the lion producers like
you're not gonna get that and you're
like we are getting this
oil battle um it was i had 11 days to do
it and people didn't think i could do it
um there's a little piece of me that was
like how are we gonna do this battle i
mean the the plane fight and old guard
that was two people in a tin can and
that was five days so how do we
do oil battle but we had such a great
plan danny and i um and polly morgan the
dp how we were going to capture all of
it and and we did
i'm always fascinated by the editing
process and ultimately that's where it
all comes together so did you have like
a much longer cut like what ended up
happening in the editing room that maybe
people would be surprised
i mean foremost i have an incredible
editor terry shropshire who's cut every
film of mine every pilot every music
video like everything so we have an
incredible collaboration and trust which
i needed on this given there were so
much footage
so little time um and i knew that she
could get it done
um you know this this is a historical
epic there's a lot of footage and um
uh there is a director's cut but it's
not dramatically different than the film
as it should be if it's dramatically
different than something went wrong in
the process
um but there's a couple scenes that are
in the deleted scenes that um they just
didn't fit for the film but i still want
an audience to see also that's why
there's blu-ray
i mean because well look you look at i
know i have to wrap it like you look at
jurassic world the new one and the
extended cuts 14 minutes longer you know
what i mean like that anyway like
there's there's always longer there's
always more yeah it's um
but yeah this was this was a fun one
oh yeah absolutely listen i want to say
congrats i already got a wrap i really
do hope it's a huge hit for you guys
thank you so much